hello everyone and welcome back to the
Lindo rossabi rapid challenge it's
Wesley stall versus magnus carlsen and
this is their second match as we already
mentioned they are playing three matches
well three of its if it's one one if not
then just do obviously and that Wesley
lost the first match so here Wesley
needs to win the match the fourth match
number three and Wesley already lost
Game one games to a game two was drawn
and this is a game three so Wesley I
really should should win to get back
into the match and it's really a wild
game with a lot of winning chances for
both sides so I hope you guys enjoy it
now let's check it out Wesley wid the
white pieces opens with night of three
now he goes for the rate the opening but
after d5 and d4 we transposing to the
Queens gambit declined we have c4n d6
and the Queens gambit declined is on the
board and g3 now Wesley goes for the for
the Catalan opening we have deke a
presidency for an outburst of the g2 we
have Bishop to b4 checked by Magnus
Bishop to d2 blocking and now a five
also very popular we have castles by
both sides and here we have night two a
three by Wesley going after the c4 pawn
but also saying to Magnus you can also
capture and play b5 if you want to
defend that pawn but by doing so you are
giving up your bishop pair so Magnus
goes for it he's he's more of a night
man anyway so Bishop captures an e3 but
Abbey captures an A 3 and B 5 now so
defending the c4 pawn and this this sim
seems to be one one of the few lines
where it is okay to defend the c-4 pawns
in structures like these and that there
are no moves rook the b1 is a known move
going after the pawn here 95 is a
non-moving opening up this discovery
towards the rook but Queen to b1 the
move Wesley plays is a new move so
already as a move 10 we have a
completely new game so the b-pawn is
under attack Magnus defends it and also
if the knight comes the bishop will not
be attacking the rook so the c6 move
doesn't make sense
we have E 4 by Wesley and now h6 taking
away the g5 square from Wesley's pieces
and now as Carlson was able to save the
pawn
he still has all eight points however
he's a bit behind on development not not
too much but he is and that's why Wesley
decides to go for the attack with the g4
he wants to play g5 and bust open the
position so Magnus goes night the h7 to
keep an eye on the g5 square and now
even h4 going for g5 and now there is a
principle interest that says that when
your opponent is attacking you on the
flank meaning then the king said or
Queens that you should counter-attack in
the center and even if you don't figure
out what to play here like Magnus he
played e5 which is the the strongest
move here but simply knowing the
principle you will be able to maybe
figure out a movie you're gonna go like
okay he's attacking me on the King said
I'm just gonna play a principle de v
move which means I'm comfort acting in
the center so it opens up the attack
towards the g4 pawn from the bishop also
puts pressure on this pawn so a lot of
things happening here and Wesley decides
to go for Knight captures on e5 yet he
grabs the point and defends the g4 pawn
with the night however d5 is a very very
interesting point being that after
captures and captures you don't really
have the option of capturing with the
Queen because of Knight g5 and ninety
five threatens mate but also threatens
the Queen also the rook is behind the
Queen so it's really just a brutal move
black does does have a four which cuts
off both diagonals but then just white
of white just picks up the pawn for
example pink after screen captures
Bishop captures again attacking the
knight and the rook and here we go into
the and extremely complicated rook a
six-night captures on h7 where Wesley
would be up up a piece but after all
it's a Bishop c3 and Bishop captures ng4
there is no way for this night to get
back into the game and at some point
probably you can play g6 and just pick
it up but it would be would be very very
complicated so this is one option
here if you go d5 how about it's a wrap
the game of course you don't have all
that much time to calculate so Wesley
goes Knight captures on e5 and the Queen
captures on d4 now putting pressure on
the night Bishop to f4 as the bishop is
also under attack so Bishop to f4
defending it
repairing both threats and now rook to
e8 put a with a double attack on
night here and Wesley finds the very
interesting Queen to see one saying to
Magnus if you try and give up your look
for two pieces with rook captures on e5
then I have this very interesting rook
to d1 and you have back rank issues here
for example if Queen to c5 if you want
to keep an eye on the rook here
raagh d8 check you can block with Nitra
faith but now just look at force on c8
you win back your piece and you cannot
move the rook otherwise you're gonna
lose this piece as well as the bishop
and that rook would it be attacking that
so very very complicated so Magnus
doesn't go for it he doesn't try and
grab this he first moves the Queen now
rook to d1 at least it doesn't come with
an attack on the Queen but it should
still post some background issues for
black again if captures just rule dat
check and you can pick up the bishop and
still have a lot of pressure across the
DA thrinng so nice to a6 Magnus starts
developing brings the knight into the
game and now Wesley goes for it as you
can see the bishop still i explaining
that rook on EA t goes for Knight
captures and c6 l okay Magnus captures
it and now he v opening up an attack
towards the roof so Queen has to move
and now Bishop Tadros rook on a eight
however Magnus has bush of characters on
g4 which opens up an attack on the
bishop but also under rook on d1 so
Wesley it figures out how to defend
Bishop to e3 he needs this move to get
the d4 square for his rook
so Queen captures an e5 getting the
Queen out of the way and only now rook
to d4 saying now okay if you capture I
can capture on g4 but Knight to f6 by
Magnus and now defending the bishop and
now Wester doesn't go all the way back
with the bishop but first Bishop to c6
he first wants the weakened the be
eighth rank before going all the way
back to g2 so rook the e6 attacking
Wesley's Bishop and only now
Wesley goes back with Bishop to g2 now
Magnus needs to get this Knight back
into the game so Knights the c5 and of
course the knight now wants to come to
d3 where it will be an incredibly strong
piece and now Wesley goes Queen to c3
for the moment there are no any super
useful discoveries as well the rook
still guards the Queen but if the
some Rudy check would definitely pick up
the Queen so a nice prophylactic move
King page 7 better avoid threats before
there are any even there and here as
Wesley is down some material he decides
to grab this on a 5 so Queen captures on
a 5 and now finally night to D 3 the
night is now an incredibly strong piece
however Wesley finds the very nice rook
to be one he goes after the b5 pawn and
you don't really have any ways of
defending it so Magnus finds a queen to
f5 and it comes with the idea of
shifting the Queen over to g6 the be on
the same file as the King and then you
will be able to do some damage with with
maybe Queen g6 and descriptive three
maybe Queens you to checkmate and so on
so look out for some b5 by Wesley Queen
to g6 and now Queen to a eight now
adding a defender to the Bishop here now
so we don't have ideas like rush up to
f3 and Bishop to h3 will not be as
powerful
so Magnus goes Knight to e5 and this is
a this is incredibly strong as it
prepares Knight to f3 check however vest
who Wesley finds a very nice solution to
his problems he plays rook to d8 now the
problem is well there's just this rook
tha to checkmate the problem and if you
go Knight to f3 check right away King h1
I pretty much solves all of White's
problems there's no way to continue the
attack there are no checks there are no
there is nothing here
so what Magnus does is he goes a knight
the ei8 and when you look at this move
it's it's really weird because you're
giving up on night here but it's not you
know and not everything is as it seems
the problem is here the best move for
white is you you might even want to
pause the video and try and figure out
the best move for white well I give you
a couple of seconds so for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
on spotting the the absolute best move
for white and pretty much the only move
that gives a whitey the advantage so for
those who just want to enjoy the show
it's king - h1 is it's still the best
move as the the previous time I asked
problem is
there's no way for black to continue
this now doesn't come with check there's
no way to pin this bishop so what would
black needs to do as black will lose a
piece and there still is the threat of
checkmate black and try something like
this to go after the age for pawn but
then after captures you're gonna capture
with check and after came to g1 you will
trade here characters captures and now
Knight f3 check but King f1 and white is
not only surviving but white is better
here as white is up a whole rook and it
is a bit crowded here in front of the
White King but nothing not in white will
not be able to handle so here after 98
King to h1 definitely the best move
however Wesley first captures the knight
and now it's a bit different now Magnus
captures the rook back we have Queen
captures and now Knight to f3 with Czech
and now it's different Wesley does go
king to h1 but here you are not so safe
so once again feel free to pause the
video and try to find the winning move
now for Magnus while I give you a couple
of seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations as it's
the only move for black to win and for
those of you who just wanna enjoy show
its Queen to d3 now the problem is
there's no defense against Queen to d1
whatever you do here still the Queen
guards b1 so you cannot block with the
rook let's say you try something like
this or any move for that matter just
queen d1 check white only has one move
Bishop f1 and queen capture series
checkmate as the Queen covers g2 and the
night covers h2 and if you try something
like Bishop captures an f3 removing one
of the one of the attackers it doesn't
help you because of Queen f1 check
you're gonna go King to h2 Queen h3
check King's you want and now after
Bishop captures there is no defense
against Queen to h1 checkmate so the
King has nowhere to go and the white can
only prolong the game a bit but it's
pointless
so after Queen to d3 Wesley played
Bishop to b2 to try and prevent Queen to
d1 maybe maybe checking if Magnus will
maybe capture with the night so maybe he
can continue
the game but magnets just played queen
capture sandy - and he was in this
position that Westley saw resigned the
game and with this game he also loses
match - which means match three will not
happen and the magnus carlsen is the
second semi finalists who will face
Hikaru Nakamura in the semi-finals so
here you resign as there is nothing more
to be done here our problem is after
Queen to e4 check yes it does look good
for example if g6 you can pick up the
denied and continue the game however a
Magnus says f5 now the Queen is under
attack and you don't have time to pick
up any pieces after the Queen moves
wherever you're gonna play Queen
captures I have to end it there is no
defense here let's say Queen f1 you can
still just play Queen captures on h4
with track the King has no squares the
knife covers all of this if you go here
just captures captures and let's say
they're from g4 check will pick up the
Queen and that's it so after queen
capture sandy to western resign the game
and a very nice victory for Magnus
Carlsen who as I mentioned goes into the
semi finals to face Hikaru Nakamura so
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
a very nice game by both of them and a
lot of winning chances for both of them
so well you know if someone has to win
and I would like to thank Jack
Hetherington Pavel Roosevelt Thomas
Connors Alexandra mana here and
Nathaniel Lemke for your contribution to
my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check -
in my previous video serum thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the Lynn
Doris ABI rapid challenge checking up on
your wonderful suggestions and whatever
else happens in the chess world so thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day